Speaker 1: All right, guys, it is time to
have a conversation that I predict many in
the audience are not going to like.
I have seen this trend over the last few days
as I and others have been covering CPAC, the
Republican conference, over the weekend.
And the trend is people saying, hey, Progressive's
Trump is over.
Forget about Trump, don't talk about Trump,
don't talk about CPAC.
Never mention Donald Trump again.
He lost.
He's gone.
He's irrelevant.
Now, I must operate in reality.
And the reality right now is that there are
two major political parties in the United
States.
One of them is the Republican Party.
And their candidate, Donald Trump, received
seventy four million votes in twenty twenty.
That very same Donald Trump easily crushed
everyone in the CPAC straw poll from this
weekend, which we looked at yesterday.
The numbers are not even close now.
I know a lot of people want to wish or do
wish Donald Trump was irrelevant, but no one
other than Trump and Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis is even polling more than one percent
right now in the CPAC straw poll.
As you can see in the results that we have
on screen, Donald Trump polled 70 percent
in the CPAC straw poll.
Ronda Santos was at twenty one.
And then you've got a bunch of one percenters,
Rand Paul, Nikki Haley, Ted Cruz and Tucker
Carlson of those people.
I think only Tucker Carlson even has a shot
at significantly growing his level of support.
Tucker Carlson decided, I want to grow my
level of support and maybe look at being the
Republican nominee partially because of his
media platform.
So I wish Trump weren't relevant, but ignoring
him won't make him irrelevant.
Trump is in complete and total control of
the Republican Party.
He owns the Republican Party right now.
We could wish him we could wish that he be
irrelevant, but he's not.
And much the same way that not paying attention
in 2016 is partially what led him to winning
the Republican primary and.
Subsequently becoming president of the United
States, pretending that this guy doesn't have
an incredibly devout, fervent, feverish following
could potentially lead to the exact same thing
in twenty, twenty four.
And there's people already e-mailing me saying
they don't want to hear it.
I was one of the people that made this mistake
in 2015 and 2016.
I overestimated the intelligence of the Republican
electorate.
When you overestimate their intelligence,
you get crushed.
And I never thought they would be so ignorant
that they would make Trump their nominee,
but they did.
And then many on the left, myself included,
didn't really take the threat of Trump seriously
in the general election.
And next thing you know, he's president of
the United States.
He's mishandling covid.
He's humiliating us globally.
And the rest is history.
Now, Trump won by very few votes in a few
states in 2016.
He lost by slightly more in twenty twenty.
But again, it was not that many votes and
not that many states that pushed the electoral
victory to Joe Biden.
The popular vote victory, of course, Biden
ran away with and this level of devotion from
the Republican Party who are activated by
imaginary threats of Joe Biden's communism
and Joe Biden's Marxism.
And Kamala Harris is socialism.
They are ripe for crushing Democrats in twenty
twenty two and twenty twenty four.
Now, political scientist Rachel Scoffer has
been writing about this quite a bit.
She feels people aren't paying enough attention.
We're going to speak to Rachel.
I believe it's on Thursday this week.
And that's assuming she's fully recovered
from her appendicitis.
She's been tweeting about it.
We wish her well and she is very concerned
about this as well.
I understand being sick of Trump and being
completely embarrassed that he's still getting
this adulation and support from the Republican
Party.
But this guy is very much in control right
now.
Is it sad that these are the people leading
the CPAC straw poll right now?
Of course, it's sad.
Is it globally humiliating that after everything
we've suffered, including, I mean, the deadly
mismanagement of the covid pandemic that Trump
did, is it globally humiliating that he's
polling 70 percent of the CPAC straw poll?
Of course it is.
It's a global humiliation, without a doubt.
But this is what it is.
And he may win and we don't gain anything
by ignoring it.
And in fact, I think we're more at risk of
that happening if we just pretend that Trump
is a bygone at this point in time.
If you disagree with me, I want to hear from
you.
But it can't be a personal attack, guys.
It really can.
If you if you believe that the left ignoring
Trump would make a difference, we disagree.
But I'm open to hearing why.
And we'll have more about this particular
story on our Instagram.
If you're not following The David Pakman Show
on Instagram at this point, I don't know what
you're doing.
Crossword puzzles maybe, which are fun, by
the way, but Instagram is cool to follow us
on Instagram at David Pakman show.
We will take a quick break and be back with
much more
right
after this.